mesdames messieurs bon dimanche Québec
cède aux pression et ouvre la porte
accueillir plus de 50 000 immigrants par
année un seuil que François Legault
avait établi durant la dernière campagne
électorale affirmant qu'il serait
suicidaire de le dépasser la carte veut
cependant imposer une condition les
nouveaux arrivants devront maîtriser le
français avant d'arriver en solde
québécois une mesure qui a pour but de
lutter contre le déclin du français une
approche résolument nationaliste qui
place la langue à l'avant-plan du
processus de sélection des nouveaux
arrivants
sa première fois que ça va être le cas
dans l'histoire du Québec pour déposer
pour pouvoir déposer une demande pour
devenir un immigrant économique au
Québec va falloir avoir une maîtrise du
français je retrouve au Québec Christine
Frechette ministre de l'Immigration de
la francisation et de l'intégration
merci d'être avec nous ça me fait
plaisir
la réforme que vous avez présentée jeudi
mais l'accent essentiellement sur la
connaissance du français pourquoi
pourquoi c'est ça la clé de vote pour
vous mais en fait on a vu un déclin de
l'usage du français suivant les
principaux indicateurs linguistiques
alors notre gouvernement est vraiment à
l'oeuvre pour faire en sorte d'utiliser
toutes les options possibles pour
stopper le déclin du français et
idéalement relancer à la hausse la
l'usage du français et bien sûr
l'immigration c'est un de ces leviers on
l'avait dit Monsieur le Gaulle a dit dès
son discours inaugural il faut que
l'immigration soit une solution pour le
fait français c'est pas la seule
solution bien sûr mais ça en est une qui
est d'importance alors on a regardé
chacun des leviers qui étaient sous
notre contrôle en tant que gouvernement
du Québec et on a utilisé les leviers à
notre disposition pour faire en sorte
d'aider le français la langue française
à travers les exigences qui seront
imposées pour l'immigration économique
donc on a vraiment plusieurs réformes
qui sont mises en place à quel point ça
fait différence à quel point ça fait une
différence de l'aborder comme ça plutôt
que de franciser les immigrants quand
une fois qu'ils sont arrivés en salle
québécois d'une part on gagne en temps
parce qu'à partir du moment où les gens
connaissent le français lorsqu'ils
immigrent ici avec les programmes
économiques mais on n'a pas besoin de
les franciser en tout cas s'ils veulent
être francisés ce sera pour améliorer
leur français mais ils partiront pas de
la case départ donc ça c'est un premier
intérêt et on va faire en sorte aussi
qu'il se tourne vers le français parce
que on sait que quand on est à Montréal
parfois on peut avoir une adhésion
davantage au milieu plus anglophone
plutôt que francophone donc en amenant
des gens qui connaissent le français
mais on pense que le fait français va
bénéficier puis on veut aussi miser
beaucoup sur la régionalisation et on
sait qu'en région l'accélération de la
vitesse de francisation est plus grande
donc c'est toutes des éléments qui
jouent à la faveur des mesures qu'on a
mises en place quelles sont les
initiatives qui font en sorte que
quelqu'un serait plus intéressant et
s'établir en région par exemple j'ai pas
vu de des incitatif très précis qui
disent allez à cette île plutôt qu'à
Montréal mais en fait dans nos processus
de sélection il y a une sorte de
processus accéléré qui se met en place
lorsqu'une personne a une offre d'emploi
validé pour un emploi en région donc ça
c'est une manière que l'on a d'amener
les gens plus en région on a aussi
financé énormément d'organismes en
région pour accompagner les immigrants
qui arrivent pour s'établir on l'espère
dans la durée donc ça aussi c'est un
élément qui peut être attirant la
qualité de vie et pas est très
différente en région Montréal ça sa
dynamique et les régions ont chacune
aussi leur dynamique donc on va
promouvoir davantage la qualité de vie
les opportunités qui s'offrent dans
l'ensemble des régions du Québec lorsque
on sensibilisera les gens à l'intérêt
qu'il y aura de s'établir au Québec on
voudra faire voir sa diversité vous
allez entreprendre des consultations
publiques pour déterminer les seuils
entre 2024 2027 vous avez deux
propositions 50 000 on avait une à 60
000 on exclut de ça les diplômés
sélectionnés encore du programme
d'expérience Québec ça veut dire que ça
pourrait monter à 70,75000 dans les
faits donc c'est plus suicidaire d'aller
au-delà du 50000 mais il faut voir que
lorsque l'expression avait été prononcée
par monsieur Legault c'était en lien
avec la langue française et là avec nos
mesures qu'on a présenté jeudi on vient
complètement changer les règles du jeu
on vient faire en sorte qu'il ne sera
plus possible de d'immigrer avec les
programmes économiques au Québec pour
qui ne parle pas tant soit peu le
français les niveaux requis sont
variables selon les emplois dont il est
question
il y avait aussi la capacité
d'accueillir ces gens-là et lorsque ce
que l'on comprend c'est que finalement
la capacité elle peut aller au-delà du
50 000 en fait c'est que avec les règles
qu'on se donne on a la capacité de
donner une préférence à ceux qui sont
déjà établis au Québec et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant pour la capacité
d'accueil parce qu'on veut pas on ne
veut pas la solliciter bien davantage
donc on va faire en sorte que ceux qui
sont déjà établis soit parce qu'ils
étudient au Québec ils auront un diplôme
québécois soit parce qu'ils sont
travailleurs temporaires déjà actif au
Québec et bien on va voir un œil plus
favorable pour ce type de profil parce
que ça va faire en sorte de pas créer
une demande additionnelle pour la
capacité d'accueil c'est des gens qui
sont déjà ici qui ont déjà un
appartement qui utilise déjà les
services gouvernementaux qui sont déjà
en processus d'intégration si en plus
ils ont étudié ici il y a pas d'enjeu de
reconnaissance des compétences ou de
reconnaissance des diplômes donc
vraiment c'est très intéressant quand
les gens sont déjà établis ici alors
c'est pourquoi on va donner une
préférence à ces gens-là pour les
prochaines parallèlement aussi on
travaille avec ma collègue à
l'habitation France Hélène Duranceau a
développé aussi des espaces immobiliers
un peu partout au Québec parce que la
capacité d'accueil elle est très limitée
dans plusieurs régions bon vous ciblez
clairement l'immigration francophone le
Canada aussi c'est de l'immigration
francophone pour contrer le déclin des
communautés francophones au Québec on
voit qu'une tendance les dernières
statistiques de plus en plus de
francophones qui vont s'installer en
Ontario dans l'ouest du pays au
Nouveau-Brunswick qu'est-ce que vous
faites pour les convaincre ces gens-là
que le Québec est une meilleure option
nous on donne pas on n'est pas contre
l'idée que des francophones aillent
s'établir ailleurs qu'au Québec il faut
que la francophonie au Québec au Canada
elles vivent elles se déploie puis je
suis contente de voir que le Canada en
fait maintenant une priorité là je veux
voir les chiffres quand au nombre de
personnes qui vont accueillir qui sont
francophones mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que aussi on veut en avoir au
Québec on va voir donc des règles qui
vont faire en sorte que les immigrants
économiques vont parler français donc
c'est sûr qu'on veut améliorer nos
processus souvent il y a des questions
de délai là qui sont entendus c'est plus
long c'est plus long au Québec c'est
plus cher c'est souvent la critique
qu'on entend puis là si vous voulez
diminuer ou pas freiner le déclin dans
le point démographique du Québec dans le
reste du Canada en misant son
immigration ils font les attirer chez
vous ces gens-là comment vous le faites
exact alors c'est une de nos trois
priorités d'améliorer les processus
c'est ça on le fait en étroite
collaboration avec le fédéral parce que
du côté du fédéral particulièrement pour
les travailleurs qualifiés les délais
sont énormes nous dans le plan qu'on a
déposé jeudi on s'engage à ce que les
travailleurs qualifiés puissent obtenir
les autorisations requises en 12 mois
donc celle qui émanent du Québec on a
six mois celle qui émaneront du fédéral
on leur donne six mois on espère qu'ils
vont respecter cet engagement là nous en
moyenne pour l'instant ça prend 50 jours
donc on est dans les délais là pour le
skier des travailleurs qualifiés on
espère que le fédéral va mettre
suffisamment de ressources et d'efforts
pour faire en sorte aussi que de 6 mois
puisse être respecté de leur côté et les
frais parce que les frais sont plus
élevés au Québec est-ce que vous allez
réduire ses frais ben nous on travaille
de notre côté du côté du Québec pour
voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut réduire comme
frais on est dans des analyses de ce
côté-là puis on incite également le
fédéral à réduire ses frais puis
lorsqu'il y a des doublons également à
éliminer les doublons il y a parfois
trop d'aller-retour entre Québec et
Ottawa pour le traitement d'un dossier
donné donc il faut améliorer on a un
devoir d'amélioration de notre
performance on en est très conscient et
on travaille là-dessus vraiment avec
l'ensemble des ressources du ministère
vous avez entendu les critiques que
Madame Fréchette la semaine dernière de
Jean parti l'opposition entre autres qui
disent vous avez un peu déchiré la
réforme de Simon Jalin vous dites quoi
ça mais en fait il fallait faire une
réforme donc c'était important au moment
où Monsieur jelin barrette a fait la
réforme d'enfer une parce qu'il y avait
un grand déséquilibre dans notre
programme d'immigration économiques les
pecs diplômés
occupaient presque toute la place et ça
rendait très difficile la sélection de
travailleurs qualifiés donc leur fallait
rétablir un équilibre ça a été fait
maintenant on peut regarder vers l'avant
et donc c'est ce pourquoi on amène des
réformes dans le PEC diplômé qui sont
vraiment intéressants donc le travail de
la réforme de Monsieur Gélin barrette
était fait c'est ce que vous me dites
puis là c'est le temps de passer à autre
chose exactement
parce qu'il y avait des inventeurs
considérables qui avaient été cumulés et
donc ça a mis des années avant d'être
rétabli l'équilibre est revenu donc on
peut se permettre de regarder vers
l'avant et d'amener des réformes comme
on l'a fait jeudi dernier donc on annule
l'exigence d'une année de travail après
l'obtention d'un diplôme pour le fait
que diplômé on annule également
l'exigence de d'être en emploi lors du
dépôt de la demande pour Le Pecq diplômé
et on a bon espoir que ce programme là
va vivre de belles heures mais il faudra
avoir obtenir un diplôme d'un programme
en français donc ça c'est une nouvelle
exigence on a instauré également une
exigence dans le français écrit donc ça
aussi c'est des c'est changement à
prendre en considération donc on va voir
qu'est-ce qui va en résulter là au cours
des prochaines années on espère attirer
beaucoup d'étudiants avec ça en
terminant je vous entendre sur on a
beaucoup parlé de du poids du Québec qui
va continuer à diminuer au sein du
Canada en fonction de l'immigration des
seuils est-ce que est-ce que ça vous
inquiète toujours est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ce que vous êtes en
train de faire ça peut s'attaquer à ça à
un moment donné c'est un des éléments
qu'il faudra discuter qu'il faudra
intégrer dans nos échanges lors de la
commission parlementaire parce que c'est
un élément de contexte on pourrait dire
qui est fort important donc c'est
apprendre à considération moi j'ai hâte
d'entendre les gens en commission
parlementaire pour voir quelle
importance si la corde ils accorde à cet
élément-là mais bien sûr il y en a
beaucoup d'autres des éléments donc ça
va être un de ceux qu'on devrait prendre
en considération et au terme de la
commission parlementaire on devra
statuer sur la suite des choses ça
pourrait faire partie de la conversion
une augmentation de ce là va peut-être
faire va faire partie de la conversation
c'est ça ça fera partie de la
conversation on va voir l'importance que
les gens lui accordent avec nos
nouvelles règles aussi comment est-ce
que ça change la donne donc c'est
vraiment un ensemble de considérations
qui devront être prises en compte lors
de la commission parlementaire et on
invite tous ceux qui sont intéressés à
prendre part au débat soit en déposant
un mémoire soit en participant à la
consultation en ligne sur le site
Internet de la Commission des Relations
avec les citoyens à y prendre part merci
infiniment d'avoir été des nôtres merci
à vous